what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and the mcu is about to
take it up a notch things are about to
get pretty crazy and it's really
exciting the fantastic four team looks
to be assembled right now or at least is
being assembled by kevin feige he seems
to have found the cast that he wants for
the film hopefully we get an
announcement soon especially with the
fantastic fort getting their director
matt shakman who directed one division
but next week is d23 and disney's d23 is
the big one yes san diego comic-con is
typically the big one as well but this
is specifically for disney and marvel
and lucasfilm get their own panel where
they've already said to be showing
exclusives and they'll be doing some
pretty big reveals as well and hopefully
we get some information about the
fantastic four but in this video let's
talk about what we should realistically
expect to see at disney's d23 from the
x-men to the fantastic four to new
projects there's a lot that could happen
so let's dive into it and if you're new
to the channel be sure to subscribe so
you don't miss out on any of the latest
videos okay so first things first about
d23 the cool thing is is we get disney
plus day the day before disney plus day
takes place on september 8th and it's
online anybody can watch it and we'll
probably do a live stream for it so look
out for that but here's the cool thing
as the title states it is disney plus
day so it is about the disney plus
projects of course they get a time to
talk about marvel and they'll probably
give us some reveals of new disney plus
shows that are going to be coming and
some trailers for some disney plush
shows that aren't here yet now this
video isn't about what to expect for
disney plus day but the cool thing is
since disney plus has their own day most
of the reveals that are going to come at
d23 are probably going to be focused on
movies since the disney plus shows
already get their own day but of course
one big thing to expect from d23 is the
reveal of phase six the full reveal of
phase six and here's where it gets fun
marvel studios has already revealed
three projects of phase six the
fantastic four is going to kick off the
phase and it's going to end with
avengers secret wars this will also end
the multiverse saga but we only have
three projects for phase 6 revealed so
we can expect to get the rest of the
projects revealed at d23 so what
projects exactly are going to be
revealed well the first one i want to
talk about is a big one and is really
important depending on how they do it it
could actually be even more important
than we're thinking and the project that
i'm talking about is deadpool 3. now
deadpool on his own is an extremely
important project to bring into the mcu
because of the fox deal and of course
his character alone is simply amazing so
to get him finally in the mcu is
fantastic however there might be sort of
a catch to deadpool coming into the mcu
and here's why we've heard some rumors
going around for a while now that
deadpool might not actually be alone
when he makes his way to the mcu he
could be bringing some friends and yes i
am talking about cable and domino and
his other friends that are with him in
the films but i'm also talking about
some x-men specifically some fox x-men
characters and let me explain what
exactly that means we know that the
mutants are coming to the mcu the only
thing is we don't exactly know when
however we do know that avengers secret
wars will be a letdown if we don't see
any x-men characters at the same time
there's a rumor that we won't get any
new mutants or an actual x-men team
until after secret wars now this is
something that we are not entirely sure
about right now however if these rumors
end up being true in the mcu not only
are we going to get mutants from the mcu
but we're also going to have some fox
mutants as well it's gonna be kind of a
blend now as far as which mutants are
going to make their way over to the mcu
with deadpool we're not exactly too sure
it could be michael fassbender's magneto
it could be james mcavoy's professor x
we're not really sure at this point but
remember we just saw patrick stewart in
multiverse of madness so anything is
possible now it kind of seems like the
plan is to only have them in the mcu
until secret wars because remember
secret wars is going to be all about
incursion so the old fox x-men
characters could be in the mcu because
of incursion or because you know
deadpool does something stupid which i'm
counting on however though it looks like
the plan is to not have any of the fox
x-men characters in the mcu after secret
wars and that's where we'll jump into
our mutants saga and i'm calling that
right now that's what i think phase
seven phase eight and phase nine are
going to be i think it's going to be the
mutant saga so one of the big
announcements that i'm expecting at d23
is for deadpool 3. and of course i'm
expecting a little bit of news about the
film as well maybe a tiny bit of a tease
of what to expect but that's just the
start deadpool 3 would be a huge
announcement but there are more to come
from d23 but first for those who are
asking about the spider-man collector's
box the thor love and thunders
collectors box or the moon knight one
from g fuel just a reminder you can get
them at gfuel.com and use my code cosmic
for a discount and this weekend starting
september 2nd my code gets you 30 off so
it's the perfect time to buy and just a
reminder it's not all energy drinks and
caffeine they also do sparkling waters
which i think tastes fantastic and if i
had to recommend anything that's what i
would but i like it all so if you want
to try some g fuel be sure to use code
cosmic so like i mentioned deadpool 3
could bring in some fox x-men characters
however even though these rumors do seem
to be somewhat legitimate there is still
a possibility that we could get a
mutants project announced we definitely
don't want to rule that out especially
because kamala khan was just announced
as the first x-men introduced in the mcu
so marvel studios clearly has a plan for
the x-men it's just a matter of when
they plan to introduce them but
hopefully one of these unknown projects
in these slots for marvel's phase six is
going to be a mutant's story maybe about
the mutants in general or maybe about a
specific mutant now there are some more
reveals but also just a reminder we
probably are going to be getting new
footage for things that we already know
is going to be coming like guardians of
the galaxy vol 3. we could be getting
the official trailer for it and ant-man
and the wasp quantum mania i'm expecting
new footage for both since we got
footage at sdcc but it was not released
to the public so hopefully for ant-man
because it's first they'll release a
trailer to the public so we can all
actually see it and of course we can
expect some new footage for wakanda
forever now if they don't show us new
footage or give us some updates about
secret invasion i would expect that here
as well but blade is one of the biggest
projects that i think we're going to be
getting an update for especially since
blade does take place in phase 5. and
after sdcc kevin feige did actually
mention the supernatural side of the mcu
so i am expecting a decent blade update
but there are still two other big
reveals that i'm really hoping we get
and the first one is nova it's already
been announced by some major trade media
outlets that the nova project is in
development at marvel studios and it is
going to be a film and nova was kind of
set up perfectly after the events of
avengers infinity war and since it's
basically confirmed right now the only
people who haven't announced it are
marvel studios hopefully they take this
opportunity to announce it after all we
are getting phase six and if it is a
part of phase six it should be announced
and the last big one that i think we're
going to be getting at d23 is a hulk
movie i won't go into too many spoilers
but if you've been watching she-hulk you
know that a hulk movie is being set up
and it's also pretty obvious that
they're doing it this falls into reports
that we are going to be getting a world
war hulk movie this was reported a while
ago actually now that she-hulk has set
it up it just makes sense that they
would announce it at d23 this could be
their biggest announcement if they don't
actually announce a mutant project and
the reason that this could be so big is
it would confirm that we are indeed
going to be getting what i'll call a
real hulk again not a smart hulk not
bruce banner and the hulk in one but
again have bruce banner and the hulk be
separate and the hulk being a true rage
monster that we know and that we love
and so far what we've kind of heard
about this film is it's sort of going to
be like a captain america civil war film
not necessarily with a ton of different
heroes but with there being two
different sides both believing that they
are right and it could be between the
hulk and his son scar a lot of people
believe that since the hulk was
completely in charge of that time when
they were on sakhar and banner has no
knowledge whatsoever the hulk could have
had a baby he could have had a son like
in the comics and that son's name is
scar but here's the deal in the comics
scar tries to kill the hulk so this
could be somewhat of a civil war a
battle between the hulk and his son scar
now realistically i think this is what
we can expect from d23 of course there
are bigger things that could happen but
i don't want to overhype it in case they
don't but hey let me know what you would
love to see announced from d23 in the
comments down below let me know what you
think about these current projects that
i think will be announced as well don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
so you can stay up to date on all things
related to the mcu for live updates you
can follow me on instagram and twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you